I think a lot of companies are saying
well hey we're already doing that we
don't we don't make these decisions
based on someone's race or their gender
or their age or any other protected
characteristic but should we be doing
something else and sometimes people want
to throw training at it and there's
unfortunately not a lot of data that
says training is very effective and even
the federal government has said that hey
I'm Dave Rubin and it's Small Business
Week here on the Rubin report joining me
today is Wendy Motor le co-owner of HR
Northwest from Seattle Washington Wendy
welcome to the show thank you very much
Dave so I know that legally I have to
ask you about what life is like in
Seattle right now with your autonomous
zone before we get into anything else of
course of course we are outside of the
autonomous zone but it seems to be
changing by the day yes are you hearing
from people that have businesses that
are in the autonomous zone or around the
autonomous zone about how they can treat
their employees or ask people to come to
work or are people not wanting to come
to work or anything else like that yes
we have clients that are outside of but
near the autonomous zone who are dealing
with the need to protect their employees
from from some some from some of the
rioting that is happening so they are
dealing with opening up late leaving
letting people leave early and otherwise
allowing employees to get out so they
can board up windows and that kind of
thing
yeah so I thought you'd be interesting
to talk to for a couple reasons because
your business sort of deals in many ways
with the business of business how do you
handle these strange situations not just
you know autonomous zones and protests
and that sort of stuff but obviously
kovat asking employees to come back to
work when everyone hears these mixed
messages from the government and from
their employers and everything else so I
guess first can you talk a little bit
about your company's sort of general
ethos and then how you apply that to
these strange times that we're in right
now sure yes what we do is we are HR
professionals we help our clients make
good business decisions with respect to
employment related matters so we try to
help our clients strike that balance
between taking care of employees and
doing right by them and then also doing
right by the business so that this
business can continue to be sustainable
and exist for a long period of time we
help our clients navigate very tricky
laws especially the more recent laws
like the FF CRA the familiesfirst Crone
a vibration response act that just
recently passed yeah you know back in
late March and there are there's just a
tangle of complexities around that so
how do you guys learn on the fly because
I know that looking at these PPE
documents and everything we signed up
for and from talking to other small
businesses it's like whether you're an
HR professional or a small business
owner or a lawyer I mean this is
seriously complex stuff that often
changes I mean every week it seems like
the rules and regulations change it is
it's changing constantly we we subscribe
to a number of different alerts with the
government with with law firms and then
we have some HR related resources that
we buy into as well but then a lot of it
is our team just keeping on top of it
reading up on the regulations themselves
and and then we're constantly kind of
discussing it with each other to make
sure that we're we're all staying on the
same page about how these should be
interpreted and utilized so what are the
types of thing
that businesses are going through right
now like some of the consistent
questions that you guys are getting as
businesses are opening up yeah a huge
question that keeps coming up is that my
employee is scared to come to work they
are they are immune compromised maybe or
they just don't want to come to work
right now because they're afraid of
coronavirus or they have some other
reason that they just feel really
uncomfortable coming in so that's been
the biggest challenge and I would say
most of the time we're seeing employers
giving people a leave of absence at
least for a few months while we all sort
of weather this storm of course it's
understandable but at some point
businesses get to a point where they say
hey this is causing serious staffing
issues now and I have to bring my people
back are you hearing a ton this is a
slight offshoot of the of the corona
thing specifically but are you hearing a
ton from employers or employees that are
now being confronted with all these
diversity and inclusion memos and all of
these things sort of a set of guidelines
that it's always seems sort of unclear
where it comes from or how they have to
apply it where suddenly you know just
hiring someone on on the basis of their
qualification is no longer good enough
yeah that is a really difficult question
we've had clients come to us and ask hey
what should we be doing around diversity
equity inclusion and should we be doing
more so we're definitely having that
conversation I personally really like to
look at the data and the research around
it and not just assume it's a hiring
problem or it's a promotion problem but
really try to try to dig into the
details I think that certainly makes
sense for companies to look at whether
they have any specific biases in their
hiring processes if it's if that's clear
that you are making these decisions
based on characteristics other than
their qualifications for the job then of
course a company should absolutely look
at that but I think a lot of companies
are saying well hey we're already doing
that we don't we don't make these
decisions based on someone's race or
their gender or their
age or any other protected
characteristic but should we be doing
something else and sometimes people want
to throw training at it and there's
unfortunately not a lot of data that
says training is very effective and even
the federal government has said that so
it is an area where we're still
grappling we're talking to various
diversity experts out there to try to
figure out what it what is the right way
to approach this problem have you seen
the general sort of business of HR
change say over the last decade or so
where now it seems like so much of it is
public where maybe back in the day if
people had a problem you complain to
your superior they take it to HR there's
some sort of process maybe it's good
maybe it isn't versus these days where
it's sort of like if something happens
to someone at work what's the first
thing you do you screenshot the email
yeah you text it to somebody at BuzzFeed
next thing you know the boss has been
fired before the company's done any sort
of research or you know an investigation
of their own yes that has added a huge
new component so now instead of
employees may be off of work having a
few beers at a local bar might have a
conversation together about something
work-related now that conversation ends
up getting broadcast and it is causing I
think a lot of harm in a lot of ways
because people aren't aren't filtering
what they're saying the information is
getting back to their boss that they
called their boss a jerk on social media
and it's causing a lot of issues and
sometimes employees get fired and that
firing is upheld when they're all
they're saying is my boss is a jerk and
sometimes the language is a lot more
colorful than that yeah that must be
interesting for you that you deal with
all sorts of different companies that
have different cultures as opposed to
being just an in-house HR team that
you're dealing you're dealing with one
boss or one culture you're dealing with
all sorts of different ones right we are
yes all sorts of different businesses
all sorts of different cultures and
environments and so we really try to
tailor what we do to that culture and
environment and
our clients well and understand what
they're trying to do so that we can help
guide their policies and their reactions
to employee questions and concerns in
that way so what should the average
person that doesn't know anything about
HR people what should we know about HR
people because I think you guys probably
get caught in the mess more than anybody
else these days we do I would say right
now HR people are all just trying to
keep up with all of the legislation and
how it all interacts together and we
work with clients in Washington Oregon
and California which have a lot of
complex state laws on top of new brand
new federal laws and it's often very
very unclear how they all are supposed
to work together I think that in general
HR people are doing their best to
navigate all of that and act as sort of
that that intermediary between senior
management and employees and of course
just like in any profession there's some
some bad apples out there too yeah all
right well now I'll let you be
saleswoman or salesperson pimp out your
website and the biz for anyone that
wants more info yeah thank you we you
can find out more information at our
website which is HRT Northwest com
it stands for Human Resources team and
Northwest just spelled out calm our
clients are generally based in
Washington and Oregon but many do have
other locations such as in California
and we really try to help businesses and
other organizations to make good
business decisions when it comes to
their employees and try to do right by
everyone nice well I thank you for doing
this and I know you guys have a unique
set of challenges up in the Pacific
Northwest these days so good luck with
everything and let me know if I can help
in any way thank you very much
appreciate it if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell